hello everyone and welcome back to the
preliminaries of the air things masters
it's daniel duba versus anish geary from
a very exciting game i know i already
uploaded three videos today
and i promise this is the last one uh
but it's a very short game i'm sure
you're gonna enjoy it
so uh let's just not waste any time and
dive straight into it
so do both after losing the game to
magnus with the white pieces
against anish giri who had a tough day
yesterday but now is trying to bounce
back in the tournament so let's see what
happens here
uh duba with the white pieces opens with
e4
now we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6
and bishop to b5 so the rule opus is on
the board
uh and knight to f6 geary goes for the
berlin defense we have castles by dubo
and now knight captures on e4 earth
sorry about that knight captures on e4
uh the real gambit we have d4 striking
in the center
and now knight to d6 attacking the
bishop here so this is nothing new
uh we have d captures on e5 sacrificing
the bishop on c4
on b5 but not really because after
knight captures
a4 uh duba attacks back the night so
this is nothing spectacular there are
over 650 games in the database
from top tier tournaments with this
exact same position so both of them of
course know this
very well knight beat the d4 this is how
you give back the piece
knight captures and now giri strikes in
the center with the d5 opening up his
light square bishop
and uh preparing to further develop and
here uh
the most common replies are captures on
b6 alpha song and
knight captures and c6 but goes for c3
and this is an extremely rare move with
bishop to e7
and now f4 strengthening the center here
uh
and there is one game in the database
where f6 was played it was played in
2019 in uh ukrainian women's
championship
uh between elizabeth and evgenia
dulhanova
and that game ended in a draw but here
gary just castles and uh it is basically
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game
so let's see how uh dubo uh deals with
it uh with bishop to e3
he continues development and now gary
strikes in the center
with f6 uh with knight captures on c6
b captures and now knights the d2
preparing to shift the knight over to f3
maybe
to d4 if needed maybe to b3 we'll see
what happens
uh bishop to a6 by giri attacking the
rook here on f1 and now double just
lifts it to rook to f3
and now f captures on e5 double
recaptures now offers a trade here of
rooks but first giri develops the queen
queen to d7
now the rooks are nicely connected and
here gary can trade and then bring the
other rook into the game
via rookie to f8 so knight to b3
now controlling this uh c5 square nicely
twice and here
gary castle uh trades as planned uh rook
captures queen captures and
rook to f8 now attacking the queen and
the queen back to g3
and here we have queen to f5 a very nice
move and
with the bishop on a6 it's very hard for
duboff to get this rook
into the game and here uh duval says
okay i definitely have some back rank
issues i'm going to play h3 make some
room on h2 for my king
and uh now it seems like uh geary's
position is very very impressive yeah he
he seems to be uh on the attack he has
two bishops
uh and uh it seems like everything is
you know
going his way but uh try and make a move
for black in this position
like if you look at it there there
really is no uh
there really is no natural move you can
make like you can't push any of the
pawns
uh if you push here you just weaken your
king would you play with the queen there
are no moves you can play with the queen
so here it's actually very very
difficult for black to make a move that
doesn't necessarily always mean your
position is bad because
maybe white also is struggling with the
moves however this is not
the case and here gary in fact goes uh
for the absolute best move he plays
queen to c2
which is one of the active moves one of
the very few active moves in the
position attacking the knight
also the b2 pawn is under attack so here
what do you play
uh it's a very delicate position so uh
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the best move for white
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting dubois
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's
bishop the c5 and it's a very very
tricky idea
basically this is uh how you save your
pieces uh
for example if bishop captures on c5
then you capture
knight captures on c5 and black has no
time to do any capturing because the
bishop on a6 is under attack and
also the knight from c5 controls e6 so
even if you go back uh e6 is just
extremely strong and now it's a
it's a really really terrible position
to play for black so that's out of the
question
so another thing after bishop to c5 is
uh
can you try and snatch the pawn maybe
you can snatch the pawn later on you can
capture the knight
well this is what happens bishop
captures an e7 okay
you're going to play rook f7 and you're
going to capture one of the two pieces
next
the problem is after bishop back to c5
and queen captures on b3
again e6 is deadly uh because now the
rook
really has no no good squares you can
try something like rook to f6 but then
bishop to d4
now uh you have to guard against
checkmates to rook to g6 pretty much
only move and now you can even play e7
this is how powerful uh dubois position
is
where if you capture the queen now it's
just pawn to e8 uh you you grab a queen
in its checkmate
or queen to b8 guarding against
checkmate but now
queen captures on c7 another beautiful
uh queen sacrifice before checkmate of
queen captures again this is checkmate
so you'd have to move the queen and then
finally rook to b1
with the idea of rook to b8 is enough to
win the game for white
so really a delicate position after
dubois bishop the c5 move this is really
crazy and kiri again
plays the absolute best move queen
captures on b3
so basically just a trade of pieces we
have bishop captures and uh sorry bishop
captures on
e7 attacking the rook here and now rook
to f7
it's a good square for the rook also you
don't want to allow e6 with tempo so
attacking the bishop makes sense with
bishop back to c5 by double
and now again a very delicate position
it's not uh easy to decide what to play
here
like for example if queen captures on b2
rookie one is enough to win the game
then uh all of these squares are pretty
much covered there's
no way to defend against e6 e7 e8
another thing uh it's very difficult to
find the move
uh queen to c4 is one such move that
allows black to continue the game with
uh a lot of pressure here on the f1
square
and also the bishop being under attack
but after the bishop is defended
and the pieces are traded here rook f1
check captures and captures with czech
king h2
again uh black's position is really
really uh
hard to play because this past e pawn is
simply too strong for example queen f5
guards the e6 square but you push it all
the same doesn't really matter queen
captures queen captures in c7
and it's uh two points on the board and
two bishops but uh there they are bishop
of
bishops of opposite colors and uh as it
usually is when you have uh
the case of bishops of opposite colors
being on the board the side who is
attacking
is uh well it's like that side is up a
piece because the light square bishop
cannot oppose the dark square bishop so
if you have some sort of an attack
it's like black would be defending being
down a piece so
it would be extremely extremely
difficult to hold this so
here uh returning to that uh famous
bishop to c5 move
after dubois played this uh geary tried
uh
bishop to c8 stopping the e6 pawn this
way
but this just completely blunders the
game so for the last time pause the
video and
win this game for duboff while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh you know
being on track with duboff's creativity
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen to g5
and there is no defense against all the
threats here just queen to da to check
will end the game
uh for example if you make a silly move
queen the 80 check will cast the block
queen captures an f8 is checkmate
there's no no way around that
so here geary cannot defend against all
of the threats he has to prevent the
checkmate he plays h5
but now duboff continues again with
queen to d8 to check and the bishop on
c8 is lost king h7 and
queen captures on c8 and now okay it's a
rapid game maybe
geary can still do some damage uh as uh
you know
uh not a lot of time uh but do of uh you
know
being up a piece is is a very formidable
opponent so queen captures and b2 was
played by giri
and immediately rook to f1 now duba
wants to trade with rook captures by
giri king captures and now
queen to c1 with check now gary will try
to pick off
all of these pawns uh uh with tempo so
he has to do it with
check king f2 queen d2 check we have
king to g1
now queen to e1 with check king the h2
and now he picks up this pawn
again with check king h1 and now there's
no way to pick it up
again with check uh well you could go
queen to e1
uh but then just bishop the g1 and you
have no more checks so first
captures on c3 now with tempo the bishop
being attacked but still uh before
retreating
first uh queen to f5 check king the g8
and now bishop to g1 and giri has a lot
of pawns
but they are not they are not fully
ready to start being pushed forward uh
d4
uh you could play it right away but uh
the the the black king
is in such a such a bad position that
you will be able to
deliver some checks and then then pick
up the d4 pawn
so instead have a5 here and now comes
queen captures on h5
and now queen to c4 uh we have queen to
e8 with
check uh king to h7 and now queen to e5
keeping an eye on the dark squares here
so c5 now preparing finally to push
those pawns and now queen captures on c7
and here just d4 uh gary has to try and
peugeot spawns the victory duboff says i
have plenty of time to grab another pawn
so queen captures on a5
queen to c1 now uh pinning this bishop
now
trying to get this pawn down the board
but simply queen to d8 stopping uh
stopping the pawns
we have queen to c3 now again preparing
to advance the pawns but now
uh we have a5 now uh duba also starts
pushing his past a pawn d3
with a6 d2 by giri and now a7
and he was in this position on mu 42
that anishigiri resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
dubo is getting another queen and
there's not nothing you can do here if
queen to a3 stopping that
uh of course adobo would very happily
trade it captures captures and now it's
very easy to pick up this pawn as well
for example queen c2 checking here
you can even capture on c5 and of course
the game is completely winning for duba
but this is all uh just uh basically
you know uh technical grind after
uh after this was uh this was played
this bishop the c8 move basically the
the game ended here on move 22
the rest was just you know a follow-up
being an extra piece
uh so yeah that's the game another
another brilliancy by dubois and you can
see how he finds
even in the real lopez which is uh so
such an analyzed opening that uh uh
these top players it's impossible to
surprise them uh in in such an opening
and especially giri who is a
master of opening theory uh duval still
finds a way to create madness on the
board and
all of these uh checkmates you've seen
in variations that didn't happen it's
just uh
very enjoyable so i hope they invite
duboff to play in absolutely every
tournament
that will ever happen because he's just
uh he's just
what we need in in you know times like
these
uh so yeah once again i do hope you
enjoyed it sorry again for so many
videos today uh i would like to thank uh
robert f
gerard christmas uh michael grouse james
talmage
and benjamin davidson for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and uh whatever else happens
in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day